alte davon ist das ziel direkt jetzt
konzentriert kosten konzentrieren ich
konnte mich okay 32
the skills und herzlich willkommen zu
meiner allerersten runde
und seltsamerweise habe sie niemanden
also ich hab mir die kommentare über das
gegeben ich meine mich zu erinnern das
ist so ein change all diesen menschen
hier auf
doch ok auf jetzt wird der wert ist als
3 2 1
richtig dass dadurch laufen aber das war
nicht der fall was alter
konzentrier dich ran zone
ich will auf der schlaufe trans kein
thema ja es geht mir schon machen wer
zwei runden gewonnen hat ich mache
einfach ansatzlos weiter will ich sagen
okay ich mache jetzt halt voller action
für euch damit ihr die zeit ist kann
dieses autoren ja also ich zeig dir märz
zum ersten mal sieht es mir nach wenn
ich jetzt hier nicht so der kreis umwelt
sei da sonst mache ich diese sprünge
okay es ist die 32 als das ist schuld
dann sei das supertalent
dann ist es richtig wenn es wirklich nur
von der kante abspringt
es ist ein thema das auch in ordnung
geht auch der ich auch nein nein es
macht erst 2 gewonnen hatte das heißt
ich bin ich schonmal naja du musst du
musst nur deinen fall huldigen alter
voll ist das ziel des konzentrierten
konzentrieren 32
ja jetzt ja ja ja ja ja ja 21 ja richtig
machen locker die
links
bis dahin laufen ja ja ja ja ja
heute das immer wieder werden stimmen
wieder abgestoßen die mir einfach nicht
mich managen konnten die war krass wie
es die nochmal wunderland hat habe ihm
spontan spontan zu auf dem nicht
geschafft deswegen mache jetzt wollt du
nimmst muss annehmen dass ist ja noch
richtig 21 kaufen so nacheinander auf
jetzt schon direkt am anfang abgepackt
das gibt mir kraft
ja ja das ist richtig
unglaublich nur zu spiel geschaut
wirtschaftsteams ja ja es ist vorbei
bald ist es geschafft wir haben gewonnen
wir haben gewonnen
erst geht's waren siegreich krass alter
ich erstmal nix ich bin ein bisschen
gestresst es war echt hart ja gut leute
wenn es euch gefallen hat das einen
daumen nach oben da dann kann man das
sicher noch mal wiederholen
vielleicht schauen wir uns dann auch
noch mal zum beispiel wunder denn immer
genauer an dann kriegen dann vielleicht
auch mal hin also dass ich gefallen hat
daumen hoch kritik in die kommentare
falls irgendwelche anmerkung habt
anderem apps die ihnen wie gut sind so
liebe spielen soll
lasst es da dann würde ich sagen macht's
gut haut rein und schlafe